if you could suddenly move your data
anywhere in the world 10 times 100 times
even a thousand times faster than you
can today
how would it transform your business
with IBM espera
you can move business critical files and
data sets at maximum speed
over your existing infrastructure and
global IP networks not just slightly
faster than what you experienced today
orders of magnitude faster regardless of
size distance or network conditions this
dramatic boost in speed is transforming
businesses around the globe from
accelerating discovery and medical
outcomes in life sciences to enabling
faster big data analytics and batch
processing for financial institutions to
speeding global engineering and design
processes with high speed file sharing
and synchronization to greatly
increasing data movement across public
private and hybrid clouds
how does IBM espera deliver these
benefits across industries by overcoming
the limitations that exist when moving
big files over long distances web
browsing FTP and other file transfer
services typically rely on the
transmission control protocol or TCP TCP
provides reliable data delivery under
ideal conditions but suffers severe
bottlenecks as transfer distances
increase or network conditions degrade
IBM Apsaras patented fast adaptive and
secure protocol fast technology reliably
moves large files and data sets at
maximum speed even over long distances
by fully utilizing available bandwidth
in addition it's unique adaptive rate
control delivers this high performance
without impacting other business
critical network services also the fast
technology is natively integrated into
all leading public cloud platforms so
data transfers can write directly to
object storage for immediate data access
enabling the fastest possible transfer
performance from end-to-end plus IBM
espera fast encrypts your data to secure
it in flight and at rest and built on
top of ASP is a complete set of ready to
use applications and solutions for
transfer collaboration automation
synchronization and streaming all in all
IBM aspera offers a dramatically faster
highly reliable and more secure way to
move your data extraordinary claims
require proof to see for yourself how
IBM espera can truly transform your
business visit us on the web or contact
us to schedule a demonstration or
evaluation